le championnat roulotte lassitude au
québec je quittais ce qu'ils disaient
pour leur apporter au groupe quitte à
lasser de l'ocs un peu sa sortie mon nom
en boule
bernard gauthier qui explique à la
commission pourquoi ce surnom lui colle
maintenant la pause mbow il se présente
en fait comme le grand défenseur des
droits des travailleurs de la côte-nord
il témoignait aujourd'hui début du
témoignage isabel richer même si son
travail a été d moniz et par plusieurs
témoins lui dit simplement se préoccuper
du sort des travailleurs de la région
oui les travailleurs qui ont beaucoup
souffert de la pénurie d'emplois et qui
ont décidé de prendre les moyens pour
assurer du travail à la main d'oeuvre
locale et lui monsieur gauthier dit j'ai
rien contre le fait que des
entrepreneurs venus d'ailleurs viennent
travailler sur la côte nord même avec
quelques hommes clés mais ils doivent
embaucher à majorité leur main d'oeuvre
dans la région et qui de mieux que lui
bernard gauthier pour désigner les
travailleurs parce que c'est lui qui les
connaît alors je vous laisse écouter
toutes deux extraits dans lesquelles il
précise sa pensée pour respecter les
règles c'est donc les règles des
conventions que les compressions exigées
il ya engagé des gens décélérateur un
manoeuvre si la gestion de ces six
cultes chez nous ça a été dit leveaux le
dire les gens ne circule dit chez nous
la convention il ya tout ce vous qui a
fait respecter
moi je dis que c'est pour ça que ça
coûte 30% plus cher ou 20%
fait ployer en poche ou et travailleurs
pour faire travailler notre monde madame
la commissaire puis 2e des choses
pourquoi ce soit toujours les mêmes qui
travaillent parce qu'on s'entend
quelqu'un surtout comme lola ne s'est
rendu ces attelages le travailleur peut
aller qu'en y apporte d'entrepreneurs
mouiller le bouton add on peut le garder
je veux travailler moins ta passion je
vous garde les je travaille et c'est pas
demain il faut que ça marche legault qui
va aller se vendre comme ça s'appelle de
la prostitution dans l'industrie -
isabelle pour vendre ces travailleurs
donc de la ftq de la côte nord est a
reconnu avoir fait de l'intimidation
voilà alors il dit que le problème
majeur c'est la mobilité provincial
d'exemple des employés des travailleurs
qui viennent d'une autre région et qui
ont droit tenir travailler sur la côte
nord est là son tempérament est ressorti
oui en a fait de l'intimidation et il a
dit à la commission si vous en voulez
pas d'intimidation
il va falloir que le gouvernement
comprenne que la mobilité provinciale
c'est inacceptable et quand les
employeurs comprennent pas le bon sens
il ya des comités qui visitent les
chantiers si vous travaillez ou comme
toujours mais s'il vous plaît pas de
contact physique
pas de manas quand son parti ne peut
plus rien vrai mais vous savez peut-être
que ça aurait peut-être des menaces à
ces moments l'onas et comme toujours ce
même si bleu marron dont julien ma
question principale vous pensez pas que
cette approche bella est pas un peu un
peu derrière la volonté gouvernementale
d'alger le placement syndical au
syndicat de donner à ses études à cette
nouvelle méthode l'a22 déblatérer pas
trop fort parce que c'est pas ça qui
fait mal gommage comprend pour ce convoi
parce que la nouvelle réforme vient
faire là dedans comme foyer patrice
bernard gauthier ne crois pas que les
abus où les petits dont les accrocs sur
la côte-nord ont eu un impact dans la
décision du gouvernement de changer
cette façon de faire le placement
syndical comme on l'appelait et pourrait
revenir à l'objet de la commission il
dit si sa cote 20% plus cher sur la
côte-nord donc des fonds publics on
pense être au québec par exemple c'est
parce que nous on faisait respecter à la
lettre les conventions puis à la lettre
c'est vraiment halal est alors que les
autres manifestement rogner un peu sur
les conditions de travail des employeurs
ce qui des employés ce qui est in action
inacceptable
très bien ça se poursuit demain
absolument revoir encore